[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y en
a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas
le procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
notre ordre du jour appelle les
explications de vote des groupes de vote
par scrutin public solennelle sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale en application de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution et ce pour
madame et monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vous rappelle que ce
scrutin
s'effectuera depuis les terminaux de
vote
je vous invite donc à vous assurer que
vous disposez bien de votre carte de
vote je m'adresse à tous les collègues
et à vérifier que celle-ci fonctionne
correctement l'insérant dans votre
terminal de vote et les Juifs sont à
votre disposition en cas de difficulté
avant de passer au vote
je vais donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote
la parole est à notre collègue Martin
lévrier pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocrates progressistes indépendants et
il a 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le Sénat
a entamé il y a 8 jours l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale troisième pelle FSS
depuis l'émergence de la pandémie de
covid-19
pour la première fois l'an prochain le
seuil symbolique des 600 milliards
d'euros devaient être dépassés en
incluant 250 240 milliards dédiés à la
dame niveau historique en progression de
3,7% par rapport à 2022 ce budget lors
de sa planification traduisez le choix
d'un système de santé renforcé emprunt
de justice pour mieux répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens et de nos
professionnels de santé
ce projet de loi de financement vous le
rappeler lundi dernier monsieur le
ministre était un texte d'engagement et
d'investissement pour notre système de
santé une première pierre à l'effort de
refondation
très concrètement pour les Français qui
nous regardent nous écoutent ce projet
de loi dans sa version originelle
permettait de trouver plus facilement un
médecin traitant d'attendre moins
longtemps aux urgences de trouver une
aide à domicile pour son parent âgé ou
en situation de handicap de bénéficier
d'un mode d'accueil pour son enfant
d'être mieux soutenu en tant que famille
monoparentale enfin de faciliter ses
déclarations URSSAF en tant
qu'entrepreneur
j'aimerais revenir sur deux mesures
phares proposées dans ce projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 d'abord le renforcement du virage
préventif qui trouve une traduction
concrète à travers la mise en place des
rendez-vous de prévention
Osage clé 20-25 ans 40 45 ans 60 65 ans
à travers la phase l'accès facilité à la
contraception d'urgence pour les femmes
majeures sans oublier la simplification
à l'accès de la vaccination en
multipliant les opportunités vaccinales
ensuite la meilleure prise en charge des
modes d'accueil du jeune enfant qui
permet de répondre aux besoins des
familles monoparentales pour les enfants
de plus de 6 ans mais aussi de diminuer
le coût des recours à une assistante
maternelle pour les parents
pour autant la majorité du Sénat n'a pas
été convaincue par ce PLFSS et au cours
de cet examen si 18 amendements du
Gouvernement ont été adoptés 96
amendements rapporteurs sont venus
améliorer mais aussi modifier la portée
de ce texte bien sûr nous avons pu
apprécier le professionnelisme de la
majorité sénatoriale qui a rétabli les
deux premières parties du PLFSS 2023
mais aussi nous réjouir pour nos aînés
entre autres de l'adoption de
l'environnement du gouvernement 1141
celui-ci major la compensation versée au
département au titre des revalorisations
prévues dans le cadre de la venant 43 à
la convention collective de la branche
de l'aide à domicile et de complément de
traitement indiciaire pour les services
d'aide à domicile de la fonction
publique territoriale
nous avons pu nous réjouir aussi de
l'adoption de l'amendement
gouvernemental 943 qui vient transformer
le système d'information des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées la stratégie d'harmonisation
de 2015 a fortement contribué à un
premier niveau de coordination des
pratiques professionnelles à
l'automatisation des échanges avec les
partenaires des MDPH à la mise en œuvre
de projets structurants ainsi qu'à la
mise à disposition et à la fiabilisation
d'indicateurs de pilotage mais ce modèle
a atteint ses limites et il est
désormais temps de basculer vers un
système d'information unique pour les
MDPH enfin notre groupe et les nombreux
Français qui peinent à accéder aux soins
peuvent se réjouir de deux améliorations
d'une part l'adoption de l'amendement
894 il permet d'étendre la condition de
durée minimum d'exercices dans un cadre
autre que des missions d'intérimaires
aux professionnels de santé mis à
disposition auprès d'un établissement
présenter si tu es en France dans le
cadre d'un contrat conclu par une
entreprise de travail temporaire établi
à l'étranger
d'autre part l'ajout de l'article 24
quaters par voie d'amendement cet
article prévoit de lancer une
expérimentation de trois ans qui
consisterait à verser au médecin en
complément de la rémunération à
l'activité un forfait financé par les
fonds d'intervention régionales ce
forfait permettra de couvrir les frais
associés au suggestions liés à leur
consultation dans les zones soudées cela
semblait évident mais notons malgré tout
que pour garantir la diversité des
territoires investis dans ce dispositif
ainsi que leur représentativité cet
amendement propose d'inclure
nécessairement un territoire ultramarin
qui pour la plupart rencontre des
difficultés accrues d'accès aux soins
malheureusement cette liste non
exhaustive d'amélioration ne peut
compenser la suppression
incompréhensible de l'article hondaam ou
encore la suppression de la dispense du
ticket medirateur pour les consultations
de prévention postérieure à 25 ans
depuis plus de 5 ans la majorité
sénatoriale veut introduire un
amendement permettant une réforme
paramétrique du régime des retraites or
la clé du système est fondée sur le
pilier de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle c'est-à-dire notre
régime de répartition le gouvernement
s'est engagé pour le réformer a lancé
une grande concertation qui doit tenir
compte d'un ensemble de paramètres
sociétaux pénibilité carrière
interrompue égalité femme homme travail
des seigneurs
tentez de résoudre les faiblesses de
notre système en cherchant en priorité
son équilibre financier est une approche
limitative les propositions du
rapporteur René Paul Savary sont
intéressantes mais inverse le calendrier
qui est déjà lancé pourquoi vouloir
décider avant d'écouter la richesse des
propositions d'un dialogue social telle
est la différence entre ce que le Sénat
veut intégrer dans le PLFSS et notre
vision du dialogue d'une véritable
réforme
vous l'aurez compris compte tenu de tous
les éléments précédents en cité notre
groupe s'abstiendra sur ce texte je vous
remercie merci
et donner la parole à notre collègue
Bernard Chaumier pour le gros socialiste
écologiste et République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
monsieur ministre madame la présente
Madame la rapporteur général mes chers
collègues ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale que nous qualifions de peu
ambitieux lors de l'addition générale
est restée plutôt fidèle à cette
appréciation
je rappelle que c'est la première fois
qu'un PLFSS arrive au Sénat après une
procédure de 49.3 notre chambre sera
donc la seule à le débattre de bout en
bout mais malgré cela le 49-3 en Audi
libération incertaine puisque le
gouvernement aura lui seul la charge
d'écrire le texte définitif le rôle du
Parlement en est de factor réduits par
ailleurs le régime des irrecevabilités a
encore restreint le débat dans des
proportions que nous jugeons excessive
nous ne pouvons continuer dans cette
voie à l'avenir
enfin la semaine a produit des débats
parfois éloignés de la réalité
légistique en introduisant des articles
sans lien direct avec une loi de
finances le gouvernement a contribué à
égarer le sens du texte et nous le
déplorons il devient urgent de présenter
une loi de santé qui tire les leçons de
la pandémie et fixe l'engagement des
collectivités territoriales dans ce
domaine
sur le fond concernant la trajectoire
financière les inquiétudes que nous
avions exprimées face à vos choix n'ont
pas reçu de réponse claire vous
présentez un budget social largement
déficit malgré nos propositions en
matière de recettes tout en investissant
pas suffisamment dans notre système de
soins en tout cas pas hauteur de ses
besoins sur les exonérations fiscales
nous continuerons de faire des
propositions utiles appuyer sur des
études telles celles du Conseil
d'analyse économique pour supprimer
celles qui sont coûteuses et inutiles
pour l'emploi l'amendement que nous
avons débattu ici a permis une bonne
discussion en ce sens et nous espérons à
l'avenir un consensus dans cette chambre
il en va de la pérennisation du
financement de notre sécurité sociale
pire et les professionnels de santé ont
du mal à le croire l'ONDAM étant dessous
de l'inflation alors que les choses
soient dites vous faites en cette année
de régression de l'épidémie mais pas de
fin de l'épidémie de covid des économies
sur le système de santé certes par
amendement le gouvernement annoncé un
financement aux 5.5 en 2022 et un budget
des hôpitaux en hausse de 3,7 en 2023
bien que ces augmentations soient
louables elles sont inférieures à
l'inflation qui je le rappelle évaluée
entre 6-2 et 6,5 cette année et autour
de 5 en 2023
des mesures sont positives bien sûr
comme dans tout PLFSS je pense par
exemple au dispositif Tod qui serait
pérennisé par nos amendements je pense
aux deux heures de soutien dédiées à
l'accompagnement en lien social pour les
personnes éligibles à la PA je pense
aussi au remboursement sans ordonnance
du dépistage des IST et à la mise en
place de consultations de prévention à
différents âges de la vie mais le texte
ne prévoit rien pour répondre à
l'urgence de l'affaissement notre
système hospitalier et il ne comporte
aucune réflexion sur l'ONDAM dont la
construction doit être vu en profondeur
malgré les propos du ministre de la
Santé de la prévention vous risquez dans
une stricte politique de l'offre au lieu
d'entamer la conversion vers une
politique des besoins en santé du pays
le rendez-vous avec la prévention reste
ainsi largement esquivé
vos prédécesseurs Marisol Touraine et
Agnès Buzyn avait trouvé consensus sur
le tabac pour rendre réduire la
consommation
votre ministère porte maintenant le
titre de prévention alors
qu'attendez-vous pour agir plus
fortement et d'ailleurs nous nous
réjouissons que ce soit le Sénat qui
rétablit la version initiale du texte
concernant le tabac chauffé certaines
n’est pas révolutionnaire mais elle a au
moins le mérite d'avoir un impact et à
l'avenir il serait sans doute préférable
que le ministre des comptes publics
évite le Congrès des buralistes avant de
défendre le PLFSS dans cette hémicycle
car nous avons le devoir de protéger la
jeunesse
par exemple s'agissant des puffs nous
accueillerons avec bienveillance les
propositions du gouvernement pour les
interdire et nous souhaitons que les
produits mêlant des arômes à l'alcool ou
au tabac soit progressivement eux aussi
interdit concernant l'alcool bien que
notre amendement qui aligné la fiscalité
de l'alcool sur l'inflation n'est pas
été votée je me réjouis de la vie
courageuse de la rapporteur général et
de la Commission à ce sujet de même je
salue l'adoption par le Sénat de la taxe
sur les prémices à base de bière et de
sucre c'est votre sont d'autant plus
importants que le gouvernement n'a pas
proposé grand chose en la matière
c'est le même constat d'ailleurs sur la
santé environnementale dont pourtant les
conséquences sur notre système de soins
font consensus s'agissant de la branche
autonomie elle reste dans un déficit de
cadre un déficit d'objectifs et
dispositif qui démontre malheureusement
trop peu de volonté politique
il n'y a toujours pas de loi autonomie
grand âge et c'est un renoncement
devons-nous nous satisfaire de cette
branche à déficit ou renoncez-vous à
toute ambition forte en la matière
enfin ce PLFSS a bien failli contenir
une réforme des retraites elle est en
discussion et nous aurons bientôt
semble-t-il l'occasion d'en débattre
quand un budget de la Sécurité sociale
se retrouve en décalage avec l'état de
notre système de soins quand il poursuit
l'esquive sur l'autonomie et le grand
âge comment imaginer la prouver nous le
repousserons depuis six ans le chef de
l'État n'a toujours pas donné de réel
impulsion à notre système social l'an
dernier j'avais dédié notre vote à
l'hôpital public cette année à cette
tribune c'est au personnel soignant que
je le dédie
en 2020 ils étaient épuisés mais fier
d'avoir accompli leurs devoirs face à la
violente épidémique qui nous a frappé en
2022 ils sont épuisés et lassés en plus
des conditions de travail ou d'exercices
qui se dégradent sans cesse ils sont au
cœur d'un service public essentiel et
précieux celui de l'état de santé de nos
concitoyens
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
vous entamez votre première année à la
tête de ce grand ministère je vous
souhaite de porter les thématiques de
santé publique d'accès de qualité des
soins alors démarquez-vous de cette
logique comptable et de la main mise de
Bercy sur nos politiques de santé
autrement vos mots volontaires resteront
des mots et nos soignants eux
renonceront de plus en plus je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes arrivés au terme de l'examen de
ce budget de la Sécurité sociale pour
2023 pour lequel nous avions déposé une
question préalable le jugeant insincert
et injuste après une semaine de débat le
bilan est toujours négatif d'autant plus
que la majorité sénatoriale l'alourdit
si nous nous réjouissons notamment de
l'annulation du transfert aux urssafs du
recouvrement des cotisations agicarco de
la suppression du transfert de charges
de 2 milliards d'euros de la branche
maladie à la branche famille et du
rétablissement de la compensation des
exonérations de cotisations de la prime
de partage de la valeur ces
modifications ne permettent pas de
revenir sur l'équilibre globale du PLFSS
pour 2023 le gouvernement prévoit une
progression des dépenses de la branche
assurance maladie de seulement 3,7%
quand il en faudrait quatre pour tenir
compte uniquement de l'évolution
naturelle des dépenses de santé chacune
et chacun le sait ici la hausse du
budget Pépito à 4,1% demeure en dessous
de niveau de l'inflation estimée par la
Banque de France à 4,7% pour 2023 les
affirmations d'auto-satisfaction du
ministre à tal ni change rien c'est la
première fois que l'on dame est en
dessous de l'inflation c'est grave
d'autant plus que certaines estimations
préfois une inflation à 6%, ce qui
revient à réaliser entre 1 et 2
milliards d'euros de coupe drastiques
sur l'hôpital public ainsi vous allez
une fois encore réduire les dépenses des
hôpitaux ce qui va entraîner des
fermetures de lit d'hospitalisation de
services et d'hôpitaux de proximité dans
tous les territoires comment ne pas être
en colère révolté de constater que les
républicains comme le gouvernement sont
incapables de faire l'autocritique de
l'échec des politiques de réduction des
dépenses de santé cela fait 30 ans que
notre système de santé est gangrené par
votre logique libérale mortifère et on
envoie les résultats des décennies de
couple budgétaires ont imposé un travail
de plus en plus pénible à l'hôpital des
organisations maltraitantes qui usent
les personnels et dégradent la qualité
des soins les personnels des secteurs de
la santé et du médico-social sont
pourtant profondément attachés au
service public et à la qualité de la
prise en charge des patientes et des
patients mais l'absence de
reconnaissance du gouvernement après une
période aussi éreintante que la covid-19
et les sacrifices personnels qu'ils ont
fait ont fait déborder le vase désormais
même les plus convaincus du sens de
l'intérêt général quitte le navire parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment d'être en
contradiction avec leurs valeurs lorsque
faute de lit et de personnels suffisant
il réalise un tri des malades et laisse
des heures entières des personnes âgées
sur les brancards comme le souligne le
collectif interhopito dans une tribune
au Monde il y a quelques jours cette
dégradation de la situation hospitalière
risque d'aboutir à la disparition de
sentiers d'activités et de savoir-faire
dont l'hôpital public est le seul
opérateur la crise de la pédiatrie
aujourd'hui
préfigura ce qui arrivera demain pour
l'ensemble de l'hôpital public face à
cette situation le gouvernement et la
droite sénatoriale préfère maintenir les
internes une année supplémentaire en
stage dans des cabinets médicaux dans
des hôpitaux pour cacher la misère
plutôt que de financer la santé à la
hauteur des besoins pourtant cette
situation n'est pas inexorable et ce
n'est pas utopiste de trouver les 5
milliards d'euros nécessaires au
recrutement de 100 000 professionnels et
à la valorisation des métiers à
l'hôpital ainsi le gouvernement aurait
pu décider par exemple de ne pas créer 5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
pour 2023 ou encore financer les 18
milliards de dépenses du covid au lieu
de les faire peser sur le budget de la
Sécu cette volonté politique vous fait
défaut car elle va à l'encontre de votre
projet politique du recul social
si vous ne l'avez pas fait c'est parce
que vous voulez déstructurer l'hôpital
public au profit du privé et fixer un
panier de soins minimaliste avec au-delà
une prise en charge assurantielle tout
au long de l'examen de ce PLFSS on a vu
un accord de fond entre le gouvernement
et la majorité sénatoriale qui ont
rejeté deux concerts tous nos
amendements sur de nouvelles recettes
refusant notamment de supprimer les
exonérations de cotisations patronales
sur les basses salaires ou de revenir
sur le cice qui pèse lourdement sur le
budget de la Sécurité sociale la droite
sénatoriale a même ajouté de nouvelles
exonérations de cotisations sociales
pour les médecins retraités qui vont
continuer d'exercer et surtout vous avez
adopté l'amendement 102 qui recule l'âge
de départ à la retraite à quatre ans et
allonge la durée de cotisation à 43
annuités infondées injuste elle va à
l'encontre de l'aspiration de 70% des
Françaises et des Français qui défendent
une retraite à 60 ans pour tout et tous
vous avez le mérite de la constance mes
chers collègues et le gouvernement bien
vous emboîtent le pas en présentant une
réforme rétrograde similaire en janvier
prochain j'ajouterai que la proximité
idéologique de la majorité sénatoriale
avec le gouvernement frise la duplicité
lorsque vous avez adopté mes chers
collègues certains vous avez refusé
d'adopter certains amendements reprenons
les précautions préconisations des
travaux parlementaires du Sénat visant à
réellement réguler le fonctionnement des
EHPAD en conclusion ce PLFSS 2023 est un
rendez-vous manqué pour les personnels
hospitaliers qui attendaient des mesures
en rupture avec les choix antérieures
afin d'améliorer leurs conditions de
travail c'est un rendez-vous manqué pour
la médecine de ville les centres de
santé les personnels des EHPAD les aides
à domicile et toutes celles et tous ceux
qui prennent soin mais c'est aussi un
rendez-vous manqué pour reprendre la
main sur la maîtrise publique de la
production de médicaments madame
lavinisme monsieur le ministre j'ai
remis au ministre de la Santé François
Brown la semaine dernière notre PPL sur
un pôle public du médicament et des
dispositifs médic est agir en ce sens
car nous ne sommes pas au bout des
ruptures de stock j'ai été alerté par
l'Observatoire de la transparence dans
les politiques du médicament des risques
de pénurie d'un antibiotique courant qui
frappe déjà les États-Unis et vous savez
pertinemment qu'il peut y avoir un effet
domino sur l'ensemble des antibiotiques
quelle mesure allez-vous prendre à court
moyen et long terme pour combattre ce
phénomène structurel pourquoi refuser de
tirer les enseignements de la crise
covid pourquoi vous obstinez-vous à
poursuivre et amplifier les mêmes
politiques dont l'échec épatant pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons les sénatrices
et sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste qui ont
porté un autre projet de société que le
vôtre pendant tous les débats voteront
contre ce plfs pour 2023 je vous
remercie mes chers collègues avec la
vérité qui blesse
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
nous pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers
sans contenu ses forces et faiblesses je
souhaite souligner sa forte portée
symbolique je le dis sans réserve la
qualité de nos débats sans être d'accord
surtout bien sûr entre les groupes mais
aussi avec les ministres au nord la
République d'ailleurs sur le terrain
dans l'opinion et même dans la sphère
médiatique les éloges sur nos travaux
fleurissent entendez-vous les mêmes
remarques que moi mes chers collègues
les débats au Sénat sont plus
intéressants à suivre que ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale vous travaillez
bien au Sénat heureusement qu'il y a le
Sénat et bien ces remarques ne sont pas
le fruit du hasard elles sont fondées
elles sont même méritées le débat sur le
plfs c'est l'occasion de souligner la
place le rôle et la responsabilité du
Sénat au moment même au moment précis où
le cocktail majorité relative et groupe
extrémiste et populiste puissant
fragilise l'Assemblée nationale
oui mes chers collègues c'est le moment
du Sénat la majorité sénatoriale est
parfaitement à la hauteur de ses
responsabilités et permettez-moi de le
constater le groupe Union centriste avec
son président Hervé Marseille qui a lui
aussi toute sa place dans cette période
si particulière je peux témoigner comme
chef de fil du groupe Union centriste
sur ce PLFSS que le Sénat trouvait toute
sa place dans le monde post dans le
monde parlementaire post-cumule et poste
loi confiance 2017 c'est vrai que c'est
les ceux qui ont emprunté la dialectique
du nouveau monde pour nous ringardiser
ou même justifiant chuchotant notre
disparition programmée sont les premiers
maintenant inventés nos mérites prenons
ce bénéfice chers collègues les
sénateurs ne se contentent pas comme je
l'ai parfois entendu de manière
pernicieuse à l'époque de rencontrer les
maires comme les visiteurs médicaux
rencontrent autrefois les médecins non
les sénateurs ne se contentent pas de
faire des relations publiques auprès des
élus pour assurer leur élection bien sûr
les sénatrices et les sénateurs
représentent les territoires les
collectivités territoriales et au
premier rang les hussards de la
République que sont les mers ils sont
mieux que cela des législateurs à part
entière qui font la loi animés par
l'intérêt général et le bien commun et
pour preuve si certains regardent
parfois de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
pour justifier une modification de notre
Constitution nous sénateurs nous ne
devons pas regarder vers les USA pour
trouver des arguments en faveur du
bicamérisme ces arguments s'effondants
on les trouve ici et maintenant
Pardonnez ce propos peut-être un peu
long mais je l'avais sur le cœur à
présent je souhaite mettre en avant le
travail de la commission des affaires
sociales en particulier celui qui a été
accompli par sa présidente Catherine
Deroche et la rapporteur général
Elisabeth Doisneau j'avais salué l'année
dernière votre première fois réussie
madame la rapporteur général la seconde
fut aussi de très bonnes factures vous
accordez madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre une importance particulière à
une meilleure prévention avec la mise en
place de rendez-vous de prévention ce
que nous saluons mais dans le même temps
nous considérons avec Jocelyne guidez
qu'il s'agit d'une mise de départ et que
la prévention ne peut s'arrêter à trois
rendez-vous dans la vie d'une personne
vous donnez la priorité au vieillir à
domicile le virage domiciliaire est une
priorité nous le soutenons mais en
l'espèce les moyens d'accompagnement
tels que l'appât ne sont plus
soutenables par les départements nous
appelons de nos vœux avec Valérie
léthard une réforme des concours de la
CNSA en attendant le Sénat l'initiative
du groupe centriste adoptait un
amendement permettant une mise en œuvre
accélérée de deux heures de temps social
au bénéfice temps des personnes des sad
que des personnes bénéficiaires de la
part surtout cet amendement permet de
limiter la part de dépenses a pas à la
charge des départements sur cette
question comme sur beaucoup d'autres il
n'est plus acceptable que l'État décide
et que les collectivités locales et
territoriales se contente de payer ou
doit se contenter de payer sur le volet
familial la décision du gouvernement de
refuser de revaloriser de moitié
l'allocation du soutien familiale en
faveur des parents isolés et l'une des
rares lueurs de ce belfs
pour la branche famille pour le reste le
transfert à la CNAV de la charge des
indemnités journalières du congé
postnatal de maternité était une mesure
qui ne trouvait aucune justification
elle démontre tout simplement le manque
d'ambition du gouvernement en matière de
politique familiale et le refus de
revenir à l'universalité des allocations
familiales qui passent par la
suppression de leur modulation pour nous
la politique familiale n'est pas une
politique sociale c'est une politique
familiale il convient d'ailleurs de
s'atteler à la création de place de
crèche nous en avons parlé ensemble
monsieur le ministre c'est une attente
des familles mais aussi une mesure
indispensable pour assurer l'égalité
homme-femme et accroître l'employabilité
enfin je vase tester sur insister sur
deux mesures qui améliorent grandement
ce PLFSS l'annulation du transfert à
l'URSSAF des cotisations de retraite
complémentaires de la jko la défense du
paritarisme et dans l'ADN du groupe
Union centriste et de la majorité
sénatoriale nous sommes les défenseurs
du dialogue social pas par dogmatisme
mais parce que les retraites agir sont
bien gérés par les partenaires sociaux
autre mesure importante celle sur les
retraites elles démontrent notre volonté
de préserver le modèle français
redistributif en maîtrisant la part des
redistributions sociales
je veux pour conclure aborder une autre
question qui me tient à cœur notre
système de santé est en train de craquer
je le dis au fort haut et fort il
souffre au moins autant du manque de
moyens que de la surademnistration ou la
sur bureaucratisation un mal bien
français je prendrai un dernier exemple
conscient de la pénurie de médecins dans
notre pays nous avons voté à l'unanimité
la fin du numerus clausus
malheureusement les conséquences de
cette décision sont décevantes et se
font attendre nous n'avons formé que de
13% de médecins en plus nous allons
former que 13%, 13% c'est ridicule la
fautaki l'administration le Conseil de
l'Ordre les doyen des facultés peu
importe mais une chose est sûre on ne
peut pas en rester là
sous peine de voir la pénurie de
médecins d'aujourd'hui s'aggraver demain
et après-demain le système est à ce
point absurde que nos étudiants les plus
brillants se trouvent contraint de se
former en Roumanie pour revenir à la fin
de leurs études exercées en France
comment comprendre qu'un grand pays
comme la France serait moins capable que
la Roumanie ou d'autres pays de faire
évoluer dans l'intérêt de tous son
système de formation mes chers collègues
le groupe UC votera ce plfs mais nous
voulions travers de cette intervention
témoigner de la fragilité de notre
système de santé et de l'urgence de
débattre d'une grande loi santé je vous
remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
venez maintenant la parole monsieur
Jean-Louis Masson pour la Réunion
administrative des sciateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre collègues
notre système de santé est très fragile
et ce PLFSS que nous votons aujourd'hui
on est l'illustration et
on ne peut pas imputer uniquement la
responsabilité de la situation actuelle
qui est dramatique dans certains dans
certains domaines au gouvernement que
nous avons actuellement je pense que ce
sont tous les gouvernements successifs
depuis plus de 20 ans qui sont
responsables des difficultés qu'on
rencontre actuellement et le l'exemple
le plus flagrant et celui de la pénurie
de médecins les véritables déserts
médicaux qui se qui se créent du fait
que même dans les grandes villes on
n'arrive plus à trouver des médecins
spécialistes qui sont dans certains
domaines comme les ophtalmos dans
d'autres domaines et qui est donc tous
nos concitoyens sont concernés alors il
est évident que le gouvernement ne peut
pas d'un seul jour rattraper tout ce qui
a été fait mais encore faudrait-il que
disons il y ait des mesures fortes qui
aillent dans le bon sens et je pense que
deux domaines sont particulièrement
sensibles d'une part la pénurie de de
personnels médicaux dans les hôpitaux et
notamment d'infirmières d'aide-soignante
etc et cette pénurie s'explique
essentiellement par le fait que depuis
des années on a sous-payé ces personnes
ces personnes n'ont pas obtenu au niveau
financier la juste reconnaissance de
leur mérite et du travail qu'elle
faisait et du diplôme
quels étaient amenées à réussir pour
exercer leur fonction et actuellement
bon certes il y a des difficultés
financières au niveau national mais
peut-être que certains choix qui ont été
faits de débloquer des financements dans
tel ou tel domaine aurait été plus
pertinent si les financements on les
avait débloqués pour contribuer à
résorber l'insuffisance du personnel
médical de l'effectif du personnel
médical et puis il y a le problème des
médecins là je même quand j'étais déjà
député ça me paraissait complètement
aberrant on avait pensé les grands
penseurs des ministères avaient estimé
que le moyen de résorber le déficit de
la Sécurité sociale consistait à réduire
le nombre des médecins bon à la limite
on aurait pu aller encore plus loin
supprimer carrément les médecins et donc
dans ces conditions on aurait encore
fait plus d'économies c'était
complètement aberrant et ce qui a de
grave c'est que on a mis des décennies
pas des années des décennies pour se
rendre pour se rendre compte qu'on
allait dans le mur et actuellement nous
sommes dans le mur et là aussi et bien
il serait pertinent que le gouvernement
prennent des mesures adéquates et
beaucoup plus volontariste que ce soit
pour augmenter les effectifs des
universités enfin des médecins dans les
universités et donc éventuellement pour
créer des
CHS supplémentaires et je pense monsieur
le ministre que dans ce domaine là vous
auriez pu certainement faire preuve d'un
peu plus d'attention aux différentes
sollicitations qui vous ont été
adressées merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Bernard fialer pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
les ministres madame le rapporteur
général madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
l'examen du PLFSS devrait être une
consultation programmée avec un
rendez-vous retenu depuis longtemps mais
avec des amendements irruptifs le jour
même ou le soir pour le lendemain sans
avis de la commission nous nous
retrouvons parfois en consultation
d'urgence pourtant tout le monde
s'accorde à reconnaître que c'est de la
prévention qui serait la réponse la plus
adaptée au monde on souffre les finances
de la sécurité sociale
certes nous saluons la réduction du
déficit convaincue que la maladie de la
dette n'a pas un bon pronostic mais ce
PLFSS se rapproche davantage d'une
compression pour contenir une hémorragie
que d'une prise en charge globale de la
maladie et les quelques très bons
amendements de notre groupe RDSE reste
des pansements sur une plaie encore trop
béante c'est une loi de programmation
globale dont sanitaire et la protection
sociale ont besoin alors on nous dit CNR
mais comme la loi d'approbation des
comptes avant le premier juin la
thérapie est insuffisante alors quel
traitement est proposé
nous saluons la mise en place des
rendez-vous de prévention moment
charnière de la vie 25-45 65 ans mais il
faut envisager aussi une consultation de
prévention supplémentaire à
l'inscription en étude supérieure moment
où la santé physique et psychique de
certains étudiants est inquiétant
nous attendons avec impatience une
conférence nationale des générations et
de l'autonomie qui doit réunir les
acteurs de la politique de soutien à
l'autonomie avec une mission prospective
de documentation des données
démographiques médicales et
socio-économiques du vieillissement et
de la dépendance
madame la Présidente de la Commission
c'est aussi engagée à mener une mission
en réponse à notre amendement de
Stéphane Artano sur le handicap
psychique
le groupe rdsa n'a pas voté l'amendement
de notre collègue René Paul Savary sur
le recul des droits à la retraite les
partenaires sociaux se sont enfin mis
autour de la table et ce sera un mauvais
signal à leur envoyer faisant leur
confiance le président Emmanuel Macron a
mis cette réforme à l'ordre du jour le
groupe RDSE est conscient de la
nécessité de réformer nos systèmes de
retraite et nous espérons que cela se
fera avec un accord des partenaires
sociaux et dans le cadre du projet de
loi attendu pour 2023
je mets un regret aussi au sujet des
infirmières en pratique avancée
l'évolution des techniques et l'exercice
de la médecine générale en auront besoin
et pas seulement pour répondre à la
démographie médicale dans 10 ans les
pratiques auront évolué avec
l'intelligence artificielle et la
robotique et les transferts de tâches
seront nécessaires pour rendre du temps
d'analyse et de synthèse au généraliste
la quatrième année du troisième cycle
des études de médecine générale pour
former aux pratiques médicales de
terrain est nécessaire
mais sa finalité ne doit pas être
l'envoi de médecins débutants peupler
les déserts médicaux elle est avant tout
une année de formation pour la
spécialité de médecine générale comme
pour toutes les autres spécialités elle
apportera naturellement du temps médical
dans les déserts médicaux
cette année devrait aussi pouvoir
s'exercer à mi-temps en hôpital de
proximité parce que l'exercice mixte
ville hôpital est en mode d'exercice
recherché par futur médecin et utile
pour nos territoires notre amendement
hélas a été rejeté
les futurs médecins doivent échapper aux
conventionnement sélectifs punitifs il
est sage de laisser les discussions
conventionnelles proposer des solutions
consensuelles pour repeupler les déserts
médicaux avec des temps dédiés dans les
zones soudainces mais proposées à tous
les praticiens d'ailleurs les
exonérations de cotisations retraite des
médecins qui cumulent emploi et retraite
pour répondre à l'actuel carence
médicale sont une démarche que nous
soutenons cela ne doit pas être une
solution de long terme mais une réponse
conjoncturelle en attendant les effets
du numerus apportus et des partages de
tâches
c'est aussi la raison de la signature
des certificats de décès par les
infirmiers le groupe RDSE avait présenté
plusieurs amendements mais je l'ai dit
l'épidémie d'articles 40 qui s'est
abattu sur nos amendements les ont
écartés
nous pouvons aussi être très inquiets de
la contamination financière du monde
médical les cliniques ne sont plus les
outils de travail des professionnels de
santé mais des investissements
financiers qui doivent devenir très
rentables pour satisfaire les
actionnaires après les cliniques et les
labos ce sont les centres de santé qui
viennent la croix de cette
marchandisation de la médecine avec des
pressions sur les professionnels
salariés que l'on inscrite apparaissent
que l'on incite à prescrire dans un
système coûteux pour les finances de la
sécurité sociale il en est de même des
réseaux de santé
optique dentaire pour l'instant c'est
une perte de liberté les professionnels
et des patients notre collègue Alain
million l'a très bien dit avec les
complémentaires santé il n'y a pas de
participation selon ses moyens et ni de
prestations selon ses besoins il faut
s'interroger sans tabou sur une sécurité
sociale universelle plus juste et moins
coûteuse et clés complémentaires
deviennent des supplémentaires
faut aussi revoir la gouvernance des
hôpitaux et l'omnipotence
administratives dont on peut mesurer les
effets iatrogènes et décentralisés
décisions et organisation en fonction
des territoires
enfin
je poursuis mon combat pour une
évolution vers un équilibre entre la
part beveridges et le système
bismarchynd sécurité sociale
que la vieillesse et les ATMP soient
financés par ceux qui travaillent mais
la santé la famille et la dépendance
peuvent l'être avec les nouvelles
répartitions de richesses de la société
par la CSG l'impôt ou de la TVA social
en diminuant les charges sur les
salaires les travailleurs seront mieux
rémunérés et les charges des entreprises
qui les emploie allégées
Emmanuel Macron l'avait initié au début
de son précédent mandat nous
encourageons le gouvernement à aller
plus loin
malgré quelques avancées intéressantes
malgré nos amendements adoptés notre
groupe se partagera et équitablement
entre abstention et votre compte le
recul de la retraite par un rendement
merci je vais donner la parole à madame
la présidente Catherine de roche pour le
Groupe Pierre républicain
[Applaudissements]
l'homme la président
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
le Ministre madame la rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues au terme de l'examen
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 force est de
constater que 26 ans après la première
édition de ce texte le contrôle
démocratique des finances sociales et
des 600 milliards d'euros de dépenses
publiques qu'elle représente reste un
sentier en cours la loi organique du 14
mars dernier avait pour objectif d'y
contribuer mais ces apports sont limités
certes pour la première fois nous avons
obtenu le montant des dotations des
agences sanitaires financées par
l'Assurance Maladie faut-il rappeler
cependant que nous en disposions de
manière détaillée lorsque ces mêmes
agences étaient financées par l'État
pour la première fois également nous
avons obtenu quelques heures avant le
vote sur l'article lui est consacré le
montant des différents sous-objectifs de
l'objectif national d'assurance maladie
Londres
au milieu d'Europe pas plus cependant
avec un montant de 240 milliards d'euros
l'ONDAM ne peut pas rester plus
longtemps une telle boîte noire c'est ce
que nous avons voulu manifester en le
rejetant tout en précisant dans le texte
les conditions dans lesquelles le
gouvernement devrait revenir devant le
Parlement en cas de dérapage nous sommes
un peu là de devoir commander les
chiffres qui nous sont pour tendus une
fois ce plfs voté je vous demande donc
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
d'engager avec nous un travail très
opérationnel sur la mise en oeuvre pour
le moins parcellaire de la loi organique
pour ce qui concerne les informations
qui nous sont communiquées
deuxième chantier d'importance le
financement de la sécurité sociale n'a
pas davantage gagné en clarté cette
année la Commission conteste chaque
année le calibrage du transfert de la
branche des accidents du travail au
titre de la sous-déclaration de la même
manière si l'on peut comprendre
l'intérêt de ne pas creuser durablement
les déficits d'une branche alors que
d'autres en excédent comment concevoir
de faire porter à la branche famille 60%
du coût des congés maternité alors que
les indemnités journalières resteront
bien versées en totalité par la branche
maladie avec cette mesure on touche à
une forme de raffinement technocratique
qui caractérise parfois ce texte mais
qui confine dans le cas d'espèces à
l'absurdité le congé poste accouchement
n'est pas plus que la grossesse à mode
de garde mais relève bien de la santé
cette année encore nous n'avons pas
échappé par nous avons par conséquent
rejeté ce transfert cette année encore
nous n'avons pas échappé à des débats de
fiscalité sectorielle à titre personnel
je suis pour le transfert à l'état de
cette inventaire à la Prévert de
taxation diverses qui n'ont qu'à loint
un rapport avec la protection sociale il
nous ferait gagner un temps précieux en
nous épargnant des délibérations sur la
C3S les biens ou certaines substances
dont l'illégalité même empêche à
l'évidence de les taxer à force d'être
lisible financement de la sécurité
sociale pour en devenir illégitime
auprès de nos concitoyens le financement
des solidarités n'est pas l'affaire des
seuls spécialistes la place des
complémentaires notamment dont nous
avons pérennisé la taxation doit être
ainsi clarifié troisième chantier
d'importance l'avenir avant la crise
sanitaire la sécurité sociale peinait à
retrouver l'équilibre sur ces deux
principaux postes de dépenses la maladie
la retraite les déficit structurelle ils
tiennent pour une large part au
vieillissement de la population une
population qui vieillit voit croître ses
besoins en transfert sociaux tandis que
les générations les plus jeunes sont
moins nombreuses pour les financer et
sont confrontés à leur propre besoin
nous sommes fiers de notre modèle
solidaire de protection sociale et nous
avons raison mais la démographie ne me
singulièrement à l'épreuve et au risque
si nous ne faisons rien de sa remise en
cause nous avons voulu apporter des
réponses concrètes sur la démographie
médicale sur l'intérim les biologistes
ou encore l'été consultations nous
espérons qu'elles seront reprises tout
comme le régime social des rachats de
RTT ou la pérennisation du dispositif
toda préparez l'avenir c'est aussi ce
que propose l'amendement de René Paul
Savary sur les retraites nous ne pouvons
pas passer plus de temps à la retraite
avec des générations plus réduites pour
les financer sans affecter la conscient
la confiance des plus jeunes dans la
solidité du pacte qui consiste à leur
offrir le moment venu la garantie que la
solidarité nationale sera aussi bien
présente pour eux la pérennité notre
modèle social suppose de leur réformer
de façon continue pour l'adapter aux
mutations de la société à l'évolution de
ses besoins sur les retraites
complémentaires agicaux le Sénat c'est
aussi inquiéter la pérennité de ce
modèle et à supprimer le recouvrement
par l'URSSAF à cet égard même si je ne
lutte pas celle de l'emploi des seniors
la question des retraites peut
finalement paraître assez simple une
affaire de paramètres celle de la
dépendance en revanche est devant nous
alors ils ont de quelques années le
besoin avant connaître une augmentation
très importante et les conditions d'un
accompagnement digne de plus âgé ne sont
pas en place il nous manque en
particulier toutes les phases
intermédiaires entre le domicile et
l'établissement dont les bases sont à
peine posées comment rendre solvable des
personnes ayant besoin d'accompagnement
d'un tiers tout en vivant elle-même de
revenus de transfert notre commission me
proposait qu'une se développe sans
tarder car la dépendance est bien un
risque et non une fatalité ce sera
l'objet de la conférence des générations
et de l'autonomie que nous avons
souhaité instituer ces différents
constats de carence nous emmenés à
rejeter la trajectoire proposée par
l'annexe B qui ne dessine en rien une
stratégie bien qu'elle intègre une
réforme des repères des retraites mais
dans les paramètres sont inconnus
permettez-moi pour conclure même si
j'interviens au nom de mon groupe de
saluer une nouvelle fois le travail des
rapporteurs de la commission qui malgré
dans des conditions particulièrement
dégradées ensuite nous proposer des axes
structurants pour l'examen de ce texte
c'est grâce à leur travail que le groupe
les républicains se prononcera en faveur
de ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
je vais donner la parole de notre
collègue Colette mélo pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
monsieur le président
madame monsieur le ministre
madame lavabra porteur général Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale comme
chaque année fut l'objet de discussions
importantes l'examen de ce texte traduit
l'équilibre financier que l'on donne à
d'autres sécurité sociale les
orientations que nous impulsons cette
année répondent à de nombreux besoins
pour nos concitoyens je salue le travail
effectué en commission des affaires
sociales par notre rapporteur général et
nos rapporteurs je me félicite de la
richesse des échanges en séance publique
alors que nous faisons encore face à des
tensions dans de nombreux secteurs de la
santé je souhaite remercier l'ensemble
des soignants pour leur engagement et
leur travail quotidien au plus près des
Français les soins et l'offre de soins
sont essentiels et doivent être répartis
sur l'ensemble du territoire afin que
chacun puisse en bénéficier c'est l'un
notre objectif absolu il en va de même
de la prévention et j'aimerais
particulièrement revenir sur ce point je
pense que nous devons poursuivre nos
efforts dans ce domaine l'information
des Français la formation des
professionnels les dépistages permettent
d'éviter des situations qui pourraient
s'aggraver rapidement les trois
consultations préventives à des âges
clés de la vie sont un bon moyen de
répondre à cet objectif la prévention
est essentielle pour la protection de
nos enfants j'y suis très attachée il
faut la développer afin de lutter contre
les différentes formes d'addiction
auxquelles les jeunes sont confrontés
les tiers-lieux sont d'ailleurs une
piste intéressante pour approcher
certaines personnes en milieu rural ou
dans des quartiers des villes je profite
de parler de prévention pour évoquer
celle de la perte d'autonomie nous avons
entendu les promesses faites et les
évolutions entérinées il faut se
concentrer sur les emplois dans ce
secteur c'est indispensable la
dépendance va augmenter entre 2020 et
2030 et l'on prév 200 000 personnes
supplémentaires concernées mon collègue
Daniel Chassin a évoqué un objectif de
50000 emplois dans le secteur nous
devons poursuivre nos efforts revenir
sur la perte d'autonomie me permet de
mettre en lumière les personnes
accompagnantes les aidants sont précieux
et consacrent une grande partie de leur
vie à l'aide d'un parent il faut saluer
leur engagement souvent source de
sacrifices je me félicite donc de
l'adoption de l'amendement concernant
l'ouverture de certaines activités des
EHPAD à certaines personnes sujettes à
des troubles cognitifs cet accueille le
jour de personnes non résidentes sera
bénéfique pour elle pour leur maintien à
domicile mais également pour soutenir
les aidants même si cela est déjà
possible il était important de le
clarifier il y a de nombreuses autres
avancées dans ce PLFSS qui auront un
impact j'en suis sûr positif sur nos
territoires l'ouverture de la
prescription et de l'administration les
accents à davantage de personnels de
santé comme les pharmaciens les
infirmières ou encore les sages-femmes
est une bonne chose concernant les
pharmaciens et plus largement le sujet
des médicaments je me félicite de
l'adoption de l'amendement concernant la
sécurisation de la filière de la vente
en gros de médicaments sujets ou combien
crucial début octobre alerté le
gouvernement sur une pénurie des
médicaments en France les tensions sur
certains médicaments les
anti-diabétiques les anticancéreux ou
encore ceux qui luttent contre
l'hypertension ne doivent pas de
persister une restructuration
structurelle comme évoquée par le
ministre et nécessaire notre groupe est
très engagé sur ce sujet autre avancées
notables la pilule du lendemain gratuite
pour toutes les femmes sans ordonnance
ou encore le dépistage des infections
sexuellement transmissibles afin
d'éviter leur propagation des grossesses
extra-utérines et des malformations
deux sujets sont encore en suspense à
l'article 23 nous avons préféré la
rédaction de la PPL examinée et votée au
Sénat concernant l'année supplémentaire
à l'internat de médecine je sais le
bruit et les oppositions que ce sujet
est provoque la rémunération lors de
cette année supplémentaire est prévu par
voie réglementaire elle doit être
suffisante ce sujet me permet d'aborder
celui des déserts médicaux cet article
ne suffira malheureusement pas à
résoudre ce problème je pense que
l'offre de formation doit être aussi
revu à ce titre j'ai pu poser une
question le mois dernier à la ministre
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé nous devons
penser la formation au plus près de nos
territoires
nous avons en Seine-et-Marne l'exemple
efficace de l'antenne de l'Université
Paris-Est Créteil à Melun je le rappelle
les étudiants s'installent très souvent
dans les lieux où ils ont effectués
leurs études ce genre de pratique doit
faire partie du panel des solutions pour
lutter contre le manque d'offres de
soins et de personnels soignants au sein
de nos territoires le second sujet est
celui de la téléconsultation qui s'est
vraiment installé dans nos habitudes
surtout depuis le début de la pandémie
de covid 19 nous sommes arrivés à
certains équilibres mais je pense qu'il
reste encore du travail ce sujet
passionnant pour l'évolution de la
médecine et nous allons au devant
d'innovation qui nous permettront de
progresser encore davantage attention
cependant tout ne peut pas se faire en
télémédecine
enfin et pour terminer la réforme des
retraites est importante le travail est
en cours et nous attendons l'arrivée
rapide d'un texte nous espérons une
proposition de réforme pour les
prochaines semaines si cela n'était pas
le cas notre groupe prendrait ses
responsabilités l'avenir des Français en
dépend ce projet de loi de la sécurité
sociale marque des avancées importantes
même si de nombreux points restent en
suspens malgré tout le groupe Les
Indépendants votre a en faveur de ce
texte
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Raymond Poncet Monge pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
n'avait la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue ce premier PLFSS
du deuxième quinquennat aurait dû enfin
tracer les lignes d'une stratégie
ambitieuse et au long cours tenant
compte des enseignements de la crise
sanitaire pour une politique sociale et
sanitaire à la hauteur des enjeux tel
n'est toujours pas le cas et nous ne
pouvons que déplorer votre impéritie
avant la covid en 2019 des milliers de
chefs de services vous alerter et
menaçait de quitter l'hôpital dans
l'incapacité de garantir des services de
qualité en 2022 une épidémie de
bronchiolite saisonnière prévisible
conduit à déclencher le plan hors-sant
prévu pour des situations
exceptionnelles imprévisibles rappelle
de personnels transferts de bébé
déprogrammations retard diagnostics
perte de chance et tri oui tri en 2022
en France alors que l'épidémie
comparable à celle de 2012 mais depuis
l'hôpital public a continué de
s'effondrer alors que lui seul assure la
pédiatrie ce qui est un scandale
monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas que
les soignants parlent de tri c'est
obliger les soignants à le faire
qu'avez-vous fait pour la pédiatrie
depuis 5 ans un gouvernement qui refuse
un nom d'âme à la hauteur mais débloque
400 millions pour passer divers quand le
scandale enfin éclate cela ne fait pas
une politique de santé cette gestion
nourrira les démissions une fois
l'urgence passée car nous leur disons
seule une vraie perspective
pluriannuelle est en capacité de donner
sens aux nouvelles efforts que vous
demandez au personnel hospitalier
épuisés vous avez fermé des lits des
postes planifier une gestion du
personnel appuyée sur des heures
supplémentaires et des primes plutôt que
des embauches et des revalorisations
pérennes et provoquer souffrance au
travail départ
suicide comme pour l'inaction climatique
vous faites désormais l'objet d'une
action judiciaire pour faire reconnaître
la responsabilité de l'État dans la
situation de l'hôpital public et nous
trouvons indécent la satisfaction du
ministre des comptes publics sur le
niveau de l'ondondam votre aveuglement
devient dangereux car refusant d'aller
chercher des ressources les asséchants
par des exonérations des extensions
d'assiettes non compensées avec vous les
dépenses publiques seront toujours à
contraindre face à des besoins en
progression vous préférerez donc
toujours le calcul comptable au défi
sanitaire et social assis vous
multipliez les mesures d'exonération de
cotisation sociale dont la part non
compensée est en hausse la Commission
des contes de la sécurité sociale note
ainsi que les crédits infectés par
l'État au titre de la compensation des
exonérations seraient inférieures de 4,3
milliards au coût global des mesures
2022 c'est milliards venaient au budget
de la Sécurité sociale représente plus
de 10 fois votre rallonge pour la
pédiatrie nous nous réjouissons donc que
l'amendement revenant sur la non
compensation des exonérations de partage
de la valeur étaient partagés par tous
les bancs du Sénat après ceux de
l'Assemblée
osez vous monsieur le ministre y revenir
par un projet un prochain 49.3 au mépris
des deux chambres de manière générale la
trajectoire financière présentée a fait
l'objet de nombreuses critiques elle
trace l'horizon de pression sur les
dépenses publiques notamment sur les
retraites sur ce dernier point nous
devons marquer une fois encore notre
opposition à la disposition introduite
pour reculer l'âge de départ là aussi
avec les mêmes points aveugles sur la
question des recettes sur les questions
de l'intensification du travail de
pénibilité d'évictions des salariés les
plus âgés insuffisamment objectifs ou
trop coûteux pour le capital car s'il y
a un seigneur sur deux hors de l'emploi
au moment de la retraite 47% le son pour
cause de licenciement à l'insuffisance
de Londres répond les maigres aux
mesures à louer à la branche autonomie
et nous ne reviendrons pas sur le
coupable retard pris dans la prévention
de la perte d'autonomie les mesures qui
y sont attachées ne prenons pas le
nécessaire choc d'attractivité qui
permettrait enfin d'ouvrir les 93.000
postes supplémentaires d'ici deux ans
pour les seuls des pads et tout autant
pour le soutien à domicile associatif
qui attend les mesures spécifiques du
Ségur pour mettre fin à son
sous-effectif alarmant
sur les autres enjeux le texte se montre
aussi insuffisant alors que plus de 3
millions de personnes vivent dans un
désert médical le gouvernement refuse
d'envisager les premières mesures
structurelles amènent de desserrer la
pénurie à court terme la quatrième année
d'internat ne peut être au service de la
régulation elle ne peut se justifier que
pour la professionnalisation
d'autres pistes restent non explorées
les études de l'adresse et de l'OMS
montrent qu'il faut mettre l'accent sur
la diversité sociale et géographique des
étudiants en médecine en favorisant
l'inscription d'étudiants originaires de
zone soudances notamment rurale et en
déconcentrant l'enseignement ce que nous
avons en vain proposé et si le
gouvernement récu régule enfin la
télémédecine il ne peut s'empêcher de
nouveau un effet de loupe sur les arrêts
maladie nous approuvons la suppression
par le Sénat du transfert de charges de
la branche maladie à la branche famille
d'autant que nous avons souligné le
caractère restrictif des mesures
présentées en faveur de la famille
limité aux familles monoparentales le
texte oublie certains foyers modestes
rappelons que la pauvreté touche un
enfant sur cinq il faut affecter une
partie des excédents pour ouvrir les
embauches nécessaires à la CNAV
revaloriser le congé parent pour ne plus
faire une trappe aux femmes pauvres mais
un choix partagé par les deux parents
pour le moment 4 enfants sur dix ne
bénéficient pas d'un mode d'accueil et
si nous pouvons saluer de la
prolongation jusqu'à 12 ans de la CMG
ainsi que les dispositions pour prévenir
la récidive des impayés des assistantes
maternelles restent nous manquons ici
l'occasion de relancer une politique au
profit des familles et des femmes car à
la source des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes se trouvent souvent
ces carrières interrompues c'est en
partiel subit pour s'occuper d'enfants à
qui aucun autre mode de garde né offert
en conclusion ce PLFSS 2023 sonne à
nouveau comme un rendez-vous manqué ce
manque de vision stratégique au moment
où l'hôpital public traverse Christ sur
crise et alors que la lutte contre la
pauvreté marque le pas et celui qui le
vote contre du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues il va être procédé dans
les conditions prévues par l'article 56
du règlement au scrutin public solennel
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
est ouvert
allez c'est parti
le scrutin est clos
le résultat du scrutin numéro 51 sur
l'ensemble du texte compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
nombre de votants 341 donc de chiffrage
exprimé
295 pour l'adoption 193 contre 102 le
Sénat à adopté et
je vais donner la parole
à Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord je souhaiterais remercier votre
hôte assemblée pour la qualité des
débats que nous avons eu sur les
branches autonomie et famille en
particulier je salue l'esprit
constructif de la rapporteur général
Elisabeth Doisneau et des rapporteurs
Philippe mouillé et Olivier Hainaut avec
lesquels le dialogue a été dès le
premier jour franc ouvert et constructif
au delà j'ai été heureux de voir
l'engagement de sénatrice et de
sénateurs de tous les bancs sur ces
sujets si importants de l'enfance au
grand âge en passant par le handicap le
texte qui vous avait été présenté était
dès le départ très ambitieux un milliard
500 millions d'euros en plus pour la
branche autonomie un milliard 600
millions d'euros en plus pour la branche
famille il a été progressivement enrichi
à l'Assemblée nationale puis ici le
texte qui ressort de votre chambre n'est
pas exactement le même car son arrivée
sur bien des points il a été modifié et
en nos désaccords ont été marqués sur
certains points et je sais ne pas avoir
toujours réussi à vous convaincre du
bien fondé des avis du gouvernement sur
les amendements que vous nous présentiez
dans beaucoup présenter un intérêt sans
forcément avoir à mon sens leur place
dans la loi mais je retiens surtout une
véritable convergence de vue sur les
grands enjeux celui de garantir d'abord
à nos aînés des conditions de vie à
domicile ou en établissement digne
sécurisante avec le soutien de
professionnel en nombre suffisant
ensuite celui d'adapter les outils de
notre politique familiale aux besoins et
aux attentes des familles avec une
attention particulière pour les plus
fragiles des familles monoparentales
chambre des collectivités vous avez
comme je l'attendais était très attentif
aux questions de compétences et de
financement des politiques
décentralisées nous avons eu l'occasion
de longuement discuter par exemple des
concours de la CNSA et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur et je me
satisfait pour ma part de l'adoption de
l'amendement porté par le gouvernement
qui permet de rehausser le plafond de
concours du concours dédié à
l'accompagnement financier de
revalorisation salariale des aides à
domicile il symbolise le dialogue de
qualité que nous avons su construire
avec l'Assemblée des départements de
France dont je salue à nouveau le
président Françoise Sauvadet je sais que
les questions relatives à la situation
financière des établissements et
services du grand âge ont aussi retenu
l'attention c'est aussi à ce titre que
je suis très heureux de vous signaler la
publication hier du décret sur le
propriétés tarifaire dans lequel figure
bien les EHPAD je salue d'ailleurs la
sénatrice Laurence Muller Braun avec
laquelle nous avions eu l'occasion de
travailler sur ce sujet dès cet été sur
la branche famille je ne doute pas que
vous serez nombreux à suivre avec
attention ces prochaines années le
déploiement des grandes réformes
engagées par le gouvernement chez un
signalé celle en particulier de la
réforme du complément mode de garde
structurante directement utile à de
nombreux foyers mais également la
création du service public de la petite
enfance dont je sais que vous serez
particulièrement attentif à
l'association des collectivités enfin un
dernier mot pour saluer à nouveau comme
je l'ai fait dès le premier jour des
débats l'action de tous les
professionnels du soin de tous les
professionnels du lien dont je sais que
nous reconnaissons tous le rôle décisif
ce texte est également pour eux
puisqu'il finance par exemple la
trajectoire de recrutement de 50 000
professionnels supplémentaires dans le
secteur médico-social en EHPAD sur les
prochaines années
mais ce texte n’épuise bien sûr pas le
débat sur les sujets d'actualité dont je
serai pour ma part heureux de continuer
à discuter avec eux mais également avec
vous dans le cadre du volet bien
vieillir du Conseil national de la
refondation je vous remercie
le ministre madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs tout d'abord
je vous prie d'excuser l'absence de
François braune retenue à l'Assemblée
nationale pour la séance des questions
au Gouvernement je souhaite vous
remercier pour la richesse de nos
échanges sur ce texte essentiel pour
protéger nos concitoyens au quotidien
nous ne sommes pas toujours tombés
d'accord comme l'a dit Jean-Christophe
combe mais je crois que nous pouvons
collectivement saluer la qualité des
débats et l'esprit d'écoute et de
responsabilité qui a prévalu tout au
long de la semaine comme ça a été salué
par un grand nombre d'entre vous le
gouvernement regrette bien sûr la
suppression de l'ONDAM pour 2023 ne
correspond pas à la réalité à la
politique ambitieuse que souhaite mener
le gouvernement dans le prolongement de
notre action depuis 2017 l'ONDAM 2023
c'est 53 milliards de plus qu'en 2017
avec un budget de 244 milliards pour la
partie santé je tiens à le souligner ce
projet de loi c'est d'abord celui de la
défense de l'hôpital pour pour la
deuxième année consécutive aucune
économie n'est demandée à l'hôpital ce
PLFSS apporte également un véritable
véritable virage préventif avec les
rendez-vous de la prévention aux HL clés
de la vie l'élargissement de la
vaccination par d'autres professionnels
mais aussi la prise en charge des
dépistages IST et d'autres mesures il
prévoit aussi des mesures concrètes pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux et
pour avancer vers la société du Bien
vieillir chez soi le Sénat a porté des
exigences fortes pour favoriser la
transparence dans les EHPAD et renforcer
nos dispositifs de lutte contre les
fraudes nous avons pu diverger sur les
moyens mais le Gouvernement partage
pleinement ses ambitions ma conviction
je le redis ce PLFSS porte une ligne
claire celle de la défense des
préoccupations essentielles de nos
concitoyens plus de prévention un accès
renforcé aux soins un système plus juste
et plus éthique c'est une première
pierre de la politique de refondation
que nous voulons engager
avec pour volonté et pour horizon
répondre à tous les besoins de santé de
tous nos concitoyens je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
remercier la présidente de la commission
Catherine de roche salué la rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales et l'ensemble des rapporteurs
Corinne Imbert
Pascal grunier René Paul Savary Olivier
Hainaut Philippe Houyet Christian
Klinger qui a rapporté pour avis pour la
commission des finances pour l'ensemble
du débat la séance est maintenant
suspendue elle sera reprise à 16 heures
en application de l'article 34-1 de la
Constitution pour l'examen d'une
proposition de résolution visant
appliqué les sanctions en en compte de
l'Azerbaïdjan et exigé son retrait média
du territoire arménien en respectant
l'accord de cessez-le-feu du 9 novembre
2020 voilà la séance est suspendue elle
sera reprise à 16 heures